字幕: Yuki Urabe
校正: Shimajiri Michiaki
(拍手)
函館から来ました 美馬です
今日は私の大好きな絵本を紹介しよう
と思ってやってきました
これは私が高校生の時に出会った絵本です
みなさんも何か一冊
そういった絵本はありますでしょうか
『ねずみ女房』
ちょっとお話を紹介したいと思います
家ねずみ 野生ではなく
人家に巣くっているねずみのことですが
その家ねずみの母親でもある主人公のねずみは
毎日夫と赤ん坊の世話に追われています
そのことだけで忙しく
あっという間に毎日が過ぎていく
でもそこに 何か物足りなさを感じています
夫はその気持ちが分からず
「これ以上 何が欲しいんだ」と言います
妻は 何が欲しいのか分からないけれど
でも まだ 今持っていない
何かが欲しかったのです
ある日 その家の主が
野生の鳩を捕らえて鳥かごで飼い始めました
えさを十分与えられているにもかかわらず
鳩はえさに口も付けず
見る見るうちにやせ衰えていきます
それを見て主人公のねずみは
私なんかと違い
毎日えさ探しをする必要もなく
贄沢な暮らしをしているのに
何が気に入らないのか 不思議に思います
鳩はねずみに話します
自分がいた世界
そこには空が広がり 風が吹き
自由に飛び回る森や木々があることを
ねずみは外の世界の話が聞きたくて
毎日鳩のもとに通います
ある日ねずみは 鳥かごの鍵を外し
鳩をもといた世界に戻すことにしました
そして その飛び立っていくところをみて
はじめて「飛ぶ」ということを理解するのです
ねずみは もう鳩の話は聞けないのだと思いつつ
みんなは知らないけれど
外にはすばらしい世界があることを
私は知っている
毎日夜空の星を見上げて
外の世界に思いを馳せ
それを誰に話すこともなく年老いていきます
30年経って この絵本を読み返してみました
あんなに好きだった絵本なのに
なにか違和感があって仕方ないのです
その違和感がどこからくるのか
なぜなのか
私には分かりませんでした
そしてこの本に出会いました
妖精の娘として生まれた主人公のローズマリーは
雲の上の金の塔のあるお城で
母親から 上品でお行儀よく
優雅な妖精になるべく
何不自由なく育てられます
ところがある日
ローズマリーはそんな生活はまっぴらごめんと
「魔女になりたい」と宣言します
母親の強い反対を押し切って家を出
暗くて恐ろしいといわれていた
魔女の森に飛び込みました
一方 母親はすぐに泣いて戻ってくるだろうと
高をくくっていました
ローズマリーがおそるおそる
魔女の世界にはいってみると
意地悪で怖いと教えられていた
魔女たちはとても親切で
おもしろい魔法をたくさん教えてくれます
最初のうちは
毎日楽しく暮らしていましたが
妖精の国にいる母親のことも
ちょっと気になりはじめ
戻ってみました
するとそこには
これまで通りの母親がいました
ローズマリーが魔女の世界のおもしろさを話しても
聞く耳を持ちません
相変わらず魔女の世界の悪口をいい
自分の住む世界が一番だというのです
そこでローズマリーは
また魔女の森へ戻っていきます
母親は心の中をよぎる
さまざまな葛藤を乗り越え
いつになっても帰ってこない娘を
連れ戻そうと意を決し
魔女の森に出かけて行きます
そこで見たのは
魔女たちと楽しそうに自由關達に暮らす
たくましいけれどかわいい娘の姿でした
娘に誘われ母親は
まる一日魔女たちと過ごします
魔女の世界も結構いいものだと母親は理解し
妖精の世界に戻っていきました
そして今では母と娘は互いの世界を
ときどき訪れるようになるという話です
この魔女の絵本の方が私にはしっくりきました
なぜ絵本の好みが変わったのか
そこでこの30年間で
自分に何が起こったのかを考えてみました
高校生の時にコンピュータに出会った私は
コンピュータは世界を変えるに違いない
と思いました
コンピュータを学べば学ぶほど
今度はこれは教育を変えるに違いないと思い始めました
そして 教育学を学びました
今度はそれを学んでいるうちに
教える道具よりも学ぶという過程を
プロセスを支援する道具を作りたいと思い
認知心理学を学びました
そしていつの間にかこの三つの分野が重なり合ったところが
ラーニングサイエンスです
学習科学という新しい分野としてできあがっています
こういったことを学んできた私は
仲間と一緒にいろいろな学習環境を
デザインし始めました
それは 1994年から今に至るまで
いろいろなものをデザインしてきました
その中で一番最初にやったのが
1994年 この
『不思議缶ネットワークの子どもたち』
として本に表したものです
これは若手の科学者を集め
小学生がもつ 日常にもつ 科学の疑問に
ネットを通じて答えていくというものです
子どもたちに科学の世界の広がりを
見せてあげたい
そして 将来来るであろう
ネットワークが コンピュータが
学校の中に入ってきたときに
新しいそこになにができるか
というその可能性を探りたい
ということもありました
子どもたちからきた質問には
こんなものがありました
「うさぎはなんではねるの？」
科学者たちは悩み
このように答えます
「動物はそれぞれの生活の仕方に適した
体の構造をしています
例えば うさぎと羊
どちらも同じように４本の足を持っているけど
その足に違いがあるのに気付くかな
答えは 羊は４本の足がほとんど同じ大きさだけど
うさぎは前の２本と後ろの２本の大きさが
全然違うということ
だから羊は４本の足を使って
歩き方が上手にできるけど
うさぎは大きな後ろ足を使って
跳ねた方が早く動く
ということができて便利なわけだ
他にも前の足に比べて
後ろの足が大きい生き物が
いるのだけれどわかるかな」
そこで子どもの返事はこんなのでした
「私 うさぎ大好きです
うちの弟もよく跳ねます」
こんなことで会話が続きません
一生懸命 答えを考えたのにこんな返事
例えば 「どうして人間は死ぬのか？」
これについても一生懸命一生懸命考えて答えましたが
返ってきた言葉は
「僕は死にたくない！」
それだけなんです
さて もう一つ
「宇宙は果てしないのか？」
これも一生懸命考えました
子どもは「果てを見せてくれ！」
それだけなのです
そういうやりとりが 噛み合わないやりとりが
９ヶ月続きました
そういう中で 変化が生まれてきました
その変化とは 自分が変化したこと
自分が成長してきたことに
気付き始めた人がでてきました
これは子どもだけではありませんでした
若手科学者の方にも出てきました
子どもは感想として述べた言葉にこんなことがあります
「自分でもどうしてこんなにたくさんの疑問を
考えられるなんて思っていませんでした
自分でも少し感心しています」
また 別の子は
「今までやってきて不思議なことがたくさんあり
世界は大きいと思いました
調べたことを積み重ねて調べていくととても楽しい」
一方 科学者の方はこんな言葉です
「質問に答えるとき
既成の概念を説明している自分を発見した
そんなことを聞きたいのでは
ないんだろうな と思いながら
かつ 自分はよく分かっていないんだろう
ということも発見しつつ
対話しているうちに
話が横にそれていくことにより
話題が膨らんでいった気がする
模範解答をするよりも
ところでそれについては
こんなこともあるんだけど
という風に面白さが移っていった」
このプロジェクトを通して
私は理解しました
「学びは双方向で起こる」ということです
話す相手がいるということ
自分が何を伝えたいのか
ということを考えるということ
それは まさに TEDxSapporo のテーマである
YOU x I
他者の存在が自己の問い直しを起こします
このプロジェクトを通して
私は学ぶとはどういうことか
どういう風に人は学ぶのか
と一生問い続ける
根源的な問いが私の中に生まれました
そのあと 仲間と一緒に
いろいろなものを作ってきました
一つはここにある1998年から始めた
今私が勤めている公立はこだて未来大学
これを一から仲間と一緒に
デザインをしてきました
2003年からは東京にある日本科学未来館
という科学館の学習環境や
そのあと 函館に戻ってからは
はこだて国際科学祭
という子どもからお年寄りまでが学ぶ
科学と社会を考えるような
そういったイベントを企画するようになりました
そして最近では
地域ブランドの開発まで手がけています
これは農家の方やパン屋さん
酪農家 研究者の人
そういう人たちと集まって
函館の近郊に自生するハーブを使って
地域のブランド品を作るということで
昨年夏 アイスクリームを発売することができました
こうやっていろいろなものを
デザインしてきた私が思うのは
これらは全てコミュニケーションと学びに
関するプロジェクトであった
ということです
コミュニケーションがあるところに
学びは生まれます
一方 コミュニケーションが断たれたところに
問題は生じています
学びの場をデザインすること
すなわち それは
コミュニケーションをデザインすることです
こういった経験をした私が
今日皆さんにお話ししたいのは
「理系女子的生き方のススメ」です
理系とありますが理系に限りません
もちろん女子とありますが女子に限りません
「的」とついている
理系女子「的」と付いているのがミソなんです
これ 分解してみます
理系的とは 好奇心にあふれ
ものごとを論理的
分析的に考える態度のことです
科学する心とは
なんか変だな 不思議だな
と感じる心
なぜ どうして と問う心
そして じゃあ それ 変えてみよう
という行動する力のことです
これが世界を変える力
未来を作る力になると考えています
一方 女子的ですが
これは 周囲を巻き込んで互いを尊重しながら
わいわいと楽しんでしまえること
これ みなさんの中にも
こういう気持ちありませんか
またその女子的とは
巻き込み力でもあります
巻き込み力とは物語る力です
私はその時大事なのは
アイディア、ビジョン、インパクト
だと思っています
つまり なにかアイディアを思いついたら
そこに至った背景や動機
そして それを行った後どうするかの展望
そして それが社会に与える影響
これを一つの物語として語りながら
仲間を集めていくんです
すなわち 理系女子的生き方とは
自分のやりたいことを見つけて
まわりを巻き込みながら
楽しく生きる生き方のことです
これを英語の単語で考えてみました
RIKEJO的
RがRespectful 互いを尊重し
さぁ 次はなんでしょう
I Investigative 知りたがり
さぁ K 難しいですよ
Knowledgeable 知識が豊かで
さぁ 次わかるかな
Enthusiastic 熱心で
さぁ 次はわかりますね きっとね
Joyful 楽しく
最後は Open 開放的で 公平で
偏見などなく
人の意見に耳を傾ける力
これが RIKEJO的
さぁ こういったことを考えている私が
じゃあどうやって物語を作って
人を集めて 仲間を集めてきたのか
一つの例は はこだて国際科学祭です
これを始める前には
英国エジンバラですでに
科学フェスティバルが行われていました
一方で函館市民はお祭り好きなんです
これを合わせたらなにかできるかも
というわけで 科学は楽しいということから
科学と社会の関係を考える
未来を考えるということをしたかったのです
そして それは科学館のない函館においても
みんなで力を合わせて
知恵を出し合えば
こういったことができるということを
全国の皆さんに知ってほしい
そういう思いがありました
これが私の物語
アイディア、ビジョン、インパクト
もう一つの物語
これは地域ブランドの開発です
クルマバソウという函館に自生するハーブがあります
これはドイツでとても有名なんだそうです
それを使って地域ブランドの開発が
できないかと思いました
そして このクルマバソウの香りが
函館の香りとして市民の中に根付くこと
全国の皆さんに知っていただくこと
そして そういったやり方が
単なる産学連携を超え
市民を巻き込みながら
このブランドが根付いていくことを考えました
アイディア、ビジョン、インパクト
30年前にあんな好きだった絵本
『ねずみ女房』
英語のタイトルは
“Mousewife” です
みなさんお気付きですか
これは1951年に出た本です
ハウスワイフですね
当時高校生だった私は
外の世界が見てみたい
もっと広がりある世界が知りたいと思った
それに重なったんだと思います
でも30年経って
私はそれだけでは物足りなかった
つまりそこから一歩踏み出して出たい
もうすでに出ていたのかもしれません
つまり新しいことが知りたい
そこで留まるのではなく
人の役に立ちたい
そしてそれを形にしたい
ということが自分の中に生まれてきたのです
それを今 函館の仲間と活動しています
これは地域でやっている活動が
日本が抱えている問題
世界が抱えている課題を解決する
糸口を示すことになるかもしれないからです
最後に今日は皆さんと
この言葉を共有して終わりたいと思います
未来を創る合言葉です
アイディア
ビジョン
インパクト
アイディア
ビジョン
インパクト
(拍手)